i think i watching all the content i
think
i think it's good i think the problem is
with a lot of guys is they're taking it
way
too i guess literal and that they're
taking it way too extreme and becoming
uh black-pilled and then you know
they're going on these posts
uh you know bashing you like the one you
posted today on twitter or you know you
got these other guys that are just going
way too far in the other spectrum
this guy was in black belt he was a gay
guy that didn't like my uh clips
okay yeah yeah but yeah but
it was all manufactured indignation like
it's basically like a care and hissy fit
right
yeah exactly have you ever dated women
like you've ever been married to a chick
like how would you even know you're gay
exactly right you don't but um
yeah i noticed that like a lot of them
but yeah there's
there's a lot of the um black pilling
from this
and that's fine like i understand that
you know some of this [ __ ] is not
comfortable and
it doesn't make you feel good but guess
what guys uh
that's part of life as a man you know it
like life is gonna be
it's like there's gonna be discomfort
the problem is is too many guys have
been bubble wrapped their entire lives
and
their mommies of helicopter parent them
and everybody gets a participation
trophy now so
you know why try and the bubble wrap's
only going to get thicker as the years
progress but you know what
p i think people got to start
understanding get focus on you that's
that's
the only way to go but um yeah no i
think
i think i'm seeing it a lot with past
friends
can you give me an example of a black
pill content creator
where we can actually see them there
isn't any they have a face they have a
you know something going on uh i haven't
seen any personally i just see it in
comment sections of
the red pill uh red pill creators
there's like an avatar
if if there's a commenter or if it's a
content creator then it's generally like
voice over right
yeah something like that yeah so i mean
i always have said to you guys consider
that you know
always consider your source consider the
source consider the source i've said it
so many times now right
how do you evaluate the source of that
information
well i mean i i look yeah i look at it
as first why go and look at the profile
whether it's you know let's say it's on
twitter if you you got to look at their
i always look at their tweets okay never
mind their replies and if their tweets
are very i don't know what the best way
to describe it if their tweets are very
black pilled or beta then i'm not going
to listen to you
because you obviously don't know what
you're talking about
you know what i mean well it's it's not
even that andrew i mean like the point
that i'm
that i'm making is how do you establish
that the source is a good reliable
source of information like
if i tell tell you guys put your
self-care first
learn combat sports but you take a look
at me
and i'm built like a pair okay i've got
no muscle
you know definition or tone but i do
because i work out because i lift
because i go and train three times a
week and i box
then what like why would i put that in
my book
talking about learning yeah combat
sports because i'm doing it myself
right and i want you guys to see that
i'm doing it myself because i'm in the
arena and i'm on it
right but then if that's not good enough
then it turns into something else like
the new thing you know lately is where's
your receipts rich
why don't you show us your girl why
don't you show us it's like
why would i show you my chick right
half of you are going to jerk off to her
and the other half you're going to say
like our eyebrows are slightly not
straight perfectly or something like
that like there's
there's no logic when it comes to
let's sit back and hate it's actually
none
it's like the whole uh i don't need to
go on the whole pandemic thing but it's
like the
you know vaccine passport but you know
applying that to
these other things
yeah there make sure this doesn't fall
over here yeah it's it's com
it's completely insane what do you got
going on there andrew gotta run
all right here i'm gonna pull you out
you let me know when you're free
you